add another accomplishment to president
trump's record
president trump becomes the first
president
in history to be impeached twice
house democrats seem to think that they
are destroying
trump's legacy if anything i think the
impeachment actually might help it
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from james
colley
who says the national guard at joey's
inauguration will be his largest crowd
that is true not just his largest crowd
you know
of of the day at the inauguration his
largest crowd ever we sort of forget
because now we've certified the election
results and joe biden's the
president-elect
we sort of forget that the guy couldn't
get more than like 12 people to show up
to any of his events
for the entire campaign and now one
suspects he's going to have mostly
a zoom inauguration it's all going to be
virtual all going to be digital
all all pretty weird won't it be
ties in a little bit to what we're going
to be talking about with
impeachment got to keep things
safe got to keep things locked down and
that's why you need
lifelock it's a new year and that
usually means one thing
new year's resolutions that most of us
probably will have a hard time
keeping there is one resolution that is
easy to keep and you will be glad that
you did
get lifelock identity theft protection
if they detect your information being
used in their network they will send you
an alert
you have access to a us-based identity
restoration specialist
to your case should you become
a victim i know what you're thinking
you're thinking nobody's after my data
no it's not a big deal maybe i'll get it
later get it now guys
there are a lot of people who want your
information and this is not
not a good time to be vulnerable on the
internet no one can prevent all identity
theft
or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but lifelock is the one new
year's resolution
that can help resolve identity theft
join now and save up to
25 off your first year go to
lifelock.com
knowles that is lifelock.com
knowles you will protect yourself you
will protect
your data on the internet and on top of
it all
you will get 25 off very important to
protect your data you know i love
lifelock you should go check them out as
well
president trump has been impeached again
this is like groundhog day i feel like
i'm bill murray
he's been impeached twice in just about
two years a little more a little more
than
no what when was it was the end of 2019
and now it's the beginning of 2021 so
just
a little over a year he's been impeached
wow are we going to impeach him again
before he is taken out of office
he won't be convicted this is the very
good news there was some rumor that
mitch mcconnell senate majority leader
was eager for impeachment do you
remember i read you that new york times
headline
just this week and i said according to
the new york times
so take that with a boulder-sized grain
of salt mitch mcconnell is looking
forward to an impeachment trial so that
he can purge the party of trump and so
that he can prevent trump from running
in 2024 i said you got to take it with a
big grain of salt
and it turns out you should because
mitch mcconnell has said that the senate
will not take up the matter of
impeachment
before the inauguration meaning the
house impeaches
then the senate holds the trial but if
president trump is no longer the sitting
president
then he cannot be the subject of an
impeachment trial
doesn't work they lost the vote
yesterday
was purely symbolic one thing that this
should remind
us first of all is you know always wait
a day when you hear something in the new
york times
and you know maybe have a little bit
more faith in cocaine mitch he's he's
served us better in recent years than
perhaps some of us thought he might
but also it reminds us how much power
one has
if uh if we control the senate you know
the fact that
republicans for at least a few more days
control the senate
means that they can say impeachment
trial completely off completely
ridiculous and democrats can't do
anything
about it there were a handful of
republicans who voted for
impeachment in the house i think it's
important to read their names
so that we can remember those names john
catko of new york adam kinzinger of
illinois
fred upton jamie buetler dan newhouse
peter miger anthony gonzalez
tom rice and tom valadao
do you recognize any of those names i
don't either they they just sound like
some gop
backbenchers uh worth remembering i
guess when they're up for re-election
obviously trump will be gone at that
point but the squishiness and the
disloyalty
and the ignorance of the law even just
on the
on the objective legal matters of the
impeachment
really makes one question their judgment
there is one name though that we can
recognize here that would be liz cheney
liz cheney daughter of dick janey
liz cheney voted for impeachment
and liz cheney is technically in
leadership
so she's not you know the minority
leader the republican minority leader in
the house or anything like that she's
not
chief whip or anything like that she is
the chairman of the gop conference and
it is a very strange thing
that someone who is at least technically
in republican leadership in the house
would vote to impeach the republican
president
with no real legal basis the legal
charge here was that
trump incited a mob to attack the
capital we played the clip on the show
you might say that trump's actions in
the last month or two have been
imprudent unwise irresponsible reckless
okay well use whatever adjective you
want
they haven't been illegal he did not
incite the mob
to commit violence at the capitol he
explicitly said be
peaceful so whatever you want to say
about trump it's a frivolous charge
dan crenshaw pointed that out just a
couple of days ago
and yet liz cheney voted for very
strange to have that kind of a person in
gop leadership
really really don't have a ton of faith
in her judgment
and i don't have faith in the judgment
of gop leadership
if they're going to have a person like
that there just worth remembering
now all of this is symbolic
but that's all they all they can voiced
on trump right now is this kind of
symbolism and what the democrats and the
never trumpers
want to do is they want to say trump
is historically bad and evil
they were hoping they could prevent him
from running in 2024 they failed to do
that but they just want to destroy his
legacy
i think they've done exactly the
opposite
i want to put aside for a second
anything about the capital
i want to put aside for a second
anything about trump's tweets i want to
put aside for a second anything about
how you don't like the cut of his jib
i want you to focus on the impeachers i
want you to focus on
not just the house democrats and the
handful of
squishy republicans i want you to focus
on the broader
ruling class guys like jack dorsey these
silicon valley oligarchs you know
hipster rasputin
who who decides that he he ought to be
able to censor
the duly elected sitting president of
the united states
i want you to think about guys like mark
zuckerberg
another zillionaire master of the
universe who decides he can censor the
duly elected president of the united
states
i want you to think about everybody over
youtube and google decides
they can censor they decide they can
censor the duly elected president of the
united states
when you think of that ruling class then
you add the corporate class to that and
then you add the higher education part
to that then you add hollywood then you
had the corrupt mainstream media
the ruling liberal class has come after
trump in a way that i've never seen them
come after any republican in my lifetime
they hated bush they hated romney even
though now they love romney they hated
mccain even though they
other times they loved mccain we know
you know way back in the olden days they
hated
reagan in particular they went after
reagan in a fairly similar way to how
they've gone after trump but they ju
it's trump is like singular
if you have faith in that ruling elite
right now
then they're impeaching trump twice
a knock on his legacy there's no
question
but if you think that that ruling elite
is corrupt
wrong-headed idiotic
malevolent in some cases certainly
malignant
if you think that that ruling elite is a
rotting oligarchy that
deserves none of our admiration or
respect
then their second impeachment of trump
is a badge of honor
taking away any argument that they made
for the impeachment the fact that
they've come after this guy
again and again and again they were so
threatened by this guy
that when he was running for president
the first time the ruling
regime decided they had to spy on him to
try to undermine his campaign
then the minute he gets inaugurated you
had democratic representatives saying
we've got to impeach him because
otherwise he might win re-election
then they try to impeach him for this
then they try to impeach him for that
then they try to impeach him for the
other thing then they finally do impeach
him for some bogus nonsense he gets
he gets acquitted he isn't convicted in
the senate then they go after him again
and again and again they rewrite the
election laws
in the weeks and months before the
election in some cases
explicitly violating state constitutions
like in pennsylvania
they're so threatened by this guy
and then they impeach him again i'll
probably try and impeach him a couple
more times is that a knock on his legacy
or is that a defense of his legacy i
think in the long run
it's going to be the latter consider
the people who are doing this nancy
pelosi
nancy pelosi and and all the rest of
them by the way
maxine think about maxine waters who
explicitly called for violence against
republicans think about
hillary clinton who said you can't be
civil with republicans think about
all of these other people but nancy
pelosi speaker of the house
she decides that the people's business
is very very important
that house democrats pass a resolution
such that the house rules will no longer
include
gendered language all the troubles we
face right now
the draconian lockdowns people losing
their livelihoods threats from abroad
rising china all of these issues
nancy pelosi says very very important we
pass this resolution
such that the house rules will not
include gendered language listen to the
arguments
she makes for that resolution this is
not theoretical
and this is not motivated by
partisanship i stand before you today as
an
officer of the constitution a speaker of
the house of representatives
i stand before you as a wife a mother a
grandmother
a daughter hold on
she wants to pass a resolution getting
rid of gendered language in the house
rules
and to defend that she says i stand
before you as a wife
a mother a grandmother
a would you call that gendered language
i think i would that sounds like the
most gendered language
you can use which is hilarious and it
shows their
sort of frivolity and ignorance but it
also shows something a little bit deeper
about all these
moral claims that they're making namely
they will not hold themselves to those
standards they will hold you to those
standards they won't hold themselves to
those standards
president trump says go peacefully
protest at the capitol
and then some violence occurs they say
off with his head basically
but they explicitly encourage violence
maxine waters right hillary clinton
don't be civil
chris cuomo comes out and says protests
don't need to be peaceful
they encourage the quote-unquote
peaceful protests that
seem inevitably to turn into these riots
they go on television they say
with buildings on fire this is a mostly
peaceful protest they bail
out the rioters like kamala harris did
and then they try to impeach trump and
some squishy republicans still don't get
it
those handful of people led by liz
cheney that we named
maybe they do get it maybe they're just
not on the right side
that's the leadership that we're talking
about
house democrats so serious
such an important body
that they are focusing on the real
issues namely
masks give me some relief by the way if
you want relief you gotta check out
relief band
relief band is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness
anxiety migraines i get those
hangovers i you know maybe on occasion
have had one or two of those
morning sickness thankfully i've never
had that chemotherapy so much more
the product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
and provides all-natural relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed relief band is the only
over-the-counter wearable device that
has been used in hospitals and oncology
clinics
to treat nausea and vomiting this is not
some
little you know two-bit thing that you
get out of a gumball machine this is
clinically proven to work
uh really really recommend it this new
year ensure nausea is never the reason
to miss out on life's important moments
right now relief band has an exclusive
offer
for michael knowles listeners if you go
to reliefband.com use promo code knowles
you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30-day money-back guarantee go to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d use promo code
knowles for 20 off you know how much i
love relief band go
check them out
house democrats are proposing a new rule
demanding that members of congress wear
a mask while they are on the house floor
or have to pay a 500 fine
the rule comes after three democrats
bonnie coleman brad schneider
and pr pramila jayapal claim they
contracted kovid19 while sheltering in
place with republican lawmakers during
the capitol hill riot they say they were
forced to share space with members of
the gop
who refused to wear masks now what's
funny about some of these claims you've
heard other
democratic lawmakers claim make these
sorts of claims before make a big deal
out of the masks and then some of them
have been caught on camera not wearing
the masks all the time
this is true of almost everybody who who
demands that people wear masks dr fauci
not least among them dr fauci remember
he threw out he tried to throw out the
baseball at the nationals game
and he had the mask on even though he's
standing in the middle of a baseball
diamond in an empty
stadium nobody's around him anywhere but
he makes a big show he's got the mask on
then he goes back
up to his seat and he's sitting with
some of his friends
right next to them and he takes the mask
off because he doesn't really care
he's not worried about it he's just
making a big show and i suspect that's
true of many of these
democratic legislators as well
it shows you what happens though when
you can control the house and the senate
so much of it is about how you can set
the rules how you can
put off certain things these masks it
would seem to me are here to stay at
least for the foreseeable future
and that's a really bad thing it's a
really bad thing that the democrats are
saying
it's very important it will help us get
back to normal it hasn't helped us get
back to normal how long are you going to
believe this folks
15 days to slow the spread just comply
just comply just comply
just another couple day couple weeks
just another couple weeks
we're coming up on a year seems like a
very very
bad idea we're going to be talking about
this two months from now i bet people
are still going to be wearing these
masks
on airplanes they're going to be wearing
them for a while i've spoken personally
to public health experts
who have told me i say when are we going
to get rid of the masks i said well you
know
maybe maybe we should just keep wearing
the masks you know it was so crazy of us
before
we used to be all these germs and we
wouldn't wear them put on the mask
comply comply comply
seems like a bad idea these are the sort
of frivolous people who impeach the
president
led by the most frivolous of all of them
alexandria ocasio-cortez
who just went on a long rant that is
both hilarious
but i think insightful she did not
realize it was insightful
but she unwittingly gave a lot of
insight into the way the left is
thinking
so she opens up in this rand describing
the tragedy
of the scourge that we've been talking
about all week you know this is the
the incarnation of evil in america it's
a pervasive problem
white supremacy you know don't you feel
you're walking around it's like you're
surrounded by skinheads wherever you go
right right well no maybe you don't know
any skinheads maybe you don't know any
neo-nazis but i am reliably informed by
the democratic party that this country
is
teaming with skinheads 75 million of
them
at least right doesn't matter that you
don't know any of them
trust me that trump supporter that you
don't talk to very much but maybe you
saw him across the street
that guy is a neo-nazi that's the white
supremacy so aoc goes on to describe the
tragedy of white supremacy
they would rather see our country
burn than to see them
be shoulder to shoulder equal
to others
that is the tragedy of white supremacy
the tragedy of white supremacy
is that it is doomed to fail
it's doomed to fail white supremacists
will never ever
ever live in a world
where they will see their fantasies come
true
ever hold on a second here
i think i was listening to what she said
did aoc said the tragedy of white
supremacy is that it will fail
that is aoc a white supremacist did i
miss something i know
politics is changing a lot minute by
minute but am i to understand that aoc
considers it a tragedy that white
supremacy will fail
and i was trying to think i thought is
it is she describing tragedy in a sort
of
shakespearean set a literary sense you
know someone who starts off like really
great and real everything's working out
really really
well and then it completely collapses no
i don't think she would say that about
white supremacists i don't think
she considers skinheads to be these
sorts of you know people where they're
heroes
and everything's going great but then ah
some character flaw makes it makes it
not work she's saying it the tragedy is
that they're they're
doomed to fail because aoc not uh not
the brightest bulb in the pack however
however
she is very effective she is very
effective
at communicating her views to rile up
her base and to rile up
our base too right she's ex she is
singularly talented
at getting her radicals riled up
but also triggering all of us right i
mean that is that is kind of her
her singular uh feature and then she
gets a lot of headlines in conservative
media and that helps her become more
popular
and that helps her amass more influence
within the democratic party and it
really
really has worked out for her pretty
well so aoc spins a good yarn
aoc during this uh during this
rant it was part of a larger riff about
how she feared for her life
during the capital riot listen to her
harrowing tale
as for myself i had
a pretty traumatizing event
happen to me um
and i do not know
if i can even disclose the full details
of that event
due to security concerns but
i can tell you that i had a very close
encounter where i thought i was going to
die
and you have all of those thoughts
um where you know at the end of your
life
and all of these thoughts come rushing
to you
and um that's what happened to a lot of
us
on wednesday um
and i thought i i did not think
i did not know if i was going to make it
to the end of that day alive
a harrowing tale you remember aoc the
other day said that almost half of
congress
died and of course that isn't true no
member of congress died
and doesn't doesn't appear that any
member of congress came even close to
dying
or really got so much as a scratch uh
which is good right
we're very glad no member of congress
was injured in in the riot
and i have no doubt it was very scary if
you were a member of congress i'm sure
it was
terrifying you don't want to experience
that sort of thing now they're taking
riots really really seriously
however where was aoc's concern
when businesses were being burned
people's houses were being
burned when people's lives were being
threatened and ended
in city upon city upon city
this summer during the blm riots where
was aoc where was her concern then
well that was good wasn't it that was
the the cry of the oppressed masses that
was a wonderful thing that we
had to encourage in our words and for
some lawmakers
with our money kamala harris bailing the
riders out of jail so they could go burn
more businesses down
i bet those business owners were pretty
afraid i bet some of them
feared for their lives some innocent
people
lost their lives many innocent people
lost their lives during the riots
that the democrats encouraged
and and and made excuses for and said
were mostly peaceful
they weren't mostly peaceful if the riot
on capitol hill was a riot
if the ride on capitol hill was not
mostly peaceful certainly
the destruction we saw around the
country during blm was not mostly
peaceful
it's amazing these democratic lawmakers
they only seem to really worry when it
affects
them but then aoc goes on and
unwittingly gives a very important
insight into the left-wing ideology
she said that the south is the democrats
for the taking
that's what we gotta do we gotta
organize and i think what we saw in
georgia
is a really good example
with black women leading the way
with multi-racial and multicultural
organizations leading the way
um we they proved
that southern states are not red states
they are suppressed states which means
the only
way that our country is going to heal
is through the actual liberation of
southern states
the actual liberation of the poor
the actual liberation of working people
from economic social and racial
oppression
that's the only way southern states are
not red states they're
suppressed states this tells you so much
about the left's ideology and the way
the left views democracy
according to the left if they lose
elections
that is simply evidence that the
election
was completely illegitimate now the
right questions election sometimes too
but it's in a very very different
way you know
if you want to hear more on this topic
and many others you don't just need to
listen to me
you don't just need to listen to ben
shapiro you don't just need to listen to
matt walsh
you can listen once again finally at
long last
to andrew clavin drew is back every
friday will be a longer show and 90
minute show
to wrap up the week there will be
special guests the first show
is this friday tomorrow it will air
friday evening
we still don't have an exact time this
stuff is happening all
live also tonight
is the big big night for the daily wire
tonight daily wire makes its entrance
into entertainment content with our
first feature film
run hide fight at 7 p.m eastern 4 pm
pacific we will air a virtual premiere
of the movie in a special episode of
backstage which will stream live over at
the daily wire website mobile and
streaming apps
as well as our youtube channel tonight's
event is free for everyone to watch
but after the live stream is over the
movie will be available exclusively
to daily wire members i really enjoyed
the movie
i got to screen it before we even
acquired the movie and i thought wow
this is this is cool it got you know
a good reaction at venice film festival
it was getting good reaction places
why why isn't it being shown well part
of that is it was a little politically
incorrect
it's not a propaganda movie it's not a
political movie but it didn't tow the
woke party line
and so we thought all right well we'll
release it very excited to bring you
great stories that hollywood refuses to
tell
we hope you will join us for tonight's
event that is 7 p.m eastern 4 pm pacific
can't wait to see you there head on over
to dailywire.com join if you're not
already a member we'll be right back
with a lot more
aoc said something very important during
her rambly
social media rant she said that it is
her view that southern states are not
red states they are suppressed states
meaning that when you go in there and
you completely change the election laws
and you get rid of election day and make
it election season
and you have widespread mail-in ballots
and you take away the election integrity
measures that have been in place for
decades
then all of a sudden democrats win and
you know maybe it takes a few extra days
to count the votes but don't worry
democrats win
now i'm not saying democrats are alone
in questioning election results
obviously republicans have been
questioning election results for months
at this point
but they are different arguments seems
to me
the republican arguments for election
integrity were hey guys we've got these
election integrity measures in place
namely you've got a
ideally you show an id so you can prove
that you are who you say you are
uh you have to show up on election day
where there are going to be poll
watchers
you need to count the ballots on
election day too while there are poll
watchers from the democrats and the
republicans
to make sure it's all good you need to
make sure that the election laws are
followed in like
for instance in pennsylvania the
constitution was violated during this
recent election
you need to do all sorts of these things
and if you don't do that
one has to ask the question why are you
getting rid of all of these election
integrity efforts
now there were some more eccentric
election arguments saying you know
the cia was involved germany was
involved and the computers and all that
uh fine i guess worth hearing the map
but we didn't see a ton of evidence for
for widespread fraud in that way but i
think the election integrity measures
totally a legitimate argument democrats
make a different argument
their arguments on the legitimacy or
illegitimacy of elections
do not focus in on those kind of
practical
tangible measures their arguments are
much broader
for democrats if
they lose an election that is sufficient
evidence that the election was rigged
okay republicans questioned the results
of this election
this was an unprecedented election in
american history the entire system was
upended in the weeks and months before
it happened
so i understand why that happened
republicans did not contest the election
in 2012 did we no
when we lost we didn't contest the
election in 2008 when we lost
no we didn't contest the election in
1996 when we lost no
didn't contest the election in 1992 when
we lost hadn't really contested
any election in modern memory what about
the democrats
they lost in 2000 they contested the
election they lost in 2004 elected
democrats contested
the certification of the electoral votes
which we were told was unprecedented a
few weeks ago
they did it in 2004. democrats contested
the election in 2016
refused to give it up hillary clinton
still insists
that she she's she was rightly going to
be the president and then russia
interfered or some other
macedonian click farms democrats
stacey abrams still appears to contend
that she's the governor of georgia
democrats always contest these elections
regardless of any that doesn't matter if
there's no change to the voter laws
and the reason they do that is for
democrats evidence of democracy
is their winning and this has
this has actual intellectual basis which
is uh
during the past century or so uh you
heard from the second wave feminists
this idea of a false consciousness
that idea was also articulated by the
father of the new left herbert marcus
marcus who came to prominence as a
thinker with the frankfurt school
this is an idea that you've heard from
antonio gramsci one of the
great thinkers of western marxism it
comes from marx himself
who describes this idea of a false
consciousness what is a false
consciousness
it's when the oppressed people don't
realize that they're repressed
and so they need consciousness raising
this was the slogan used by the
feminists in the 1970s
the version of it that we use today is
called raising awareness we need to
raise awareness what's the same concept
the idea is that oppressed people
maybe you know a black person or a
homosexual
or an immigrant votes for a republican
they might do it but that's not
legitimate because they are
are laboring under a false consciousness
if they were fully conscious of their
own oppression they would realize how
bad the republicans are they would vote
for democrats
and that is the subtle premise sometimes
not so subtle premise
of all of these democratic
challenges to elections and that is what
aoc is saying
and and she even goes into it further
she's saying it's not just the southern
states
it's people on the basis of social
status and economic status
race and this and that the other thing
they need to have their consciousness
raised they need to stop being
suppressed
and they need to be to use her words
liberated
and you can't be liberated by the forces
uh
the illiberal forces of republicans or
conservatives
we cannot tolerate the intolerance of
conservatives
or republicans well this also comes from
herbert marcusa this
very influential thinker of the new left
or i suppose
earlier than the new left but he kind of
gave birth to the new left her
marcus wrote this very famous essay
called repressive tolerance
in which he said that what we need for a
liberating tolerance
we need to suppress and censor views
from the right
and we need to encourage views from the
left we need to have a new standard the
old standards are suppressing radicalism
so we need a new standard and that's
going to suppress conservatism
that is what they mean by democracy i
don't think aoc understands that's what
she means
i don't think she's a particularly
sophisticated thinker but she has been
steeped in this kind of ideology and
that's what she's
that's what she's communicating
shows you how naive these republicans
are who would ever
side with them who would vote to impeach
without a legal basis
naive or playing for the other side
these are nasty guys on the other side
you think trump is nasty
wait until you hear the guys on the
other side jake tapper you know straight
laced jake tapper
calls it like he sees it you know he's
he's fair
he's old school he's the last journalist
in america jake tapper
or he's a democrat hack which is i think
it's maybe the latter jake tapper
was just describing a uh a
congressman member of congress who he
doesn't like and he
he used the most disrespectful language
i've heard from cnn in
at least several hours the reams of
evidence that we have there's one other
thing i want to share but just one other
thing just
that's relevant what you're saying right
now is relevant because congressman
brian mast
a republican from florida who lost his
legs by the way fighting for democracy
abroad
although i don't know what i don't know
about his commitment to it here in the
united states
he said did anybody say that yes yeah we
heard him the answer is yes
yes yes brian mast who lost his legs
fighting for democracy abroad
huh i i don't think he cares too much
about democracy here
what do you mean he doesn't care about
democracy here
first of all very very disrespectful
thing you can tell jake tapper knows
that he's crossed a line because he
hesitates when he says it
and usually jake tapper is good at
keeping a straight face but even that he
thought oh
yikes that's ugh well whatever i'm just
going to make the nasty comment
but he's using democracy in exactly the
same way aoc is
there is nothing undemocratic about
pursuing legal challenges to an election
nothing undemocratic about it at all
there is nothing undemocratic about
objecting to the certification of
certain electoral votes
now if for instance
mike pence had come out and unilaterally
declared that he was going to reject
the electoral votes that would have
raised some issues that would have
thrust us into a constitutional crisis
we've actually seen that that
constitutional crisis happened before
that would have happened in 1876
in 1877 but still that would have been a
crisis
but to go out and follow the procedures
that are available to you
in a democracy as the people's
representative and object to certain
votes that's not
anti-democratic the reason jake tapper
thinks it's anti-democratic
is because it's a guy on the other side
i don't remember jake tapper ever
referring to the many many democratic
lawmakers who have objected to electoral
votes as anti-democratic did he no
of course not because if you support
the democratic party you support
democracy and if you support the
republican party
you're a neo-nazi skinhead fascist who
should be de-platformed
who should be ostracized from society
who should not be able to engage in
commerce
that's ramping up too we went through it
yesterday on the show
president trump can't even use his bank
accounts in certain places now
parlor build your own twitter the left
told us okay we built our own twitter
they said you can't do that can't engage
in commerce can't engage in society
republicans need to wise up to this sort
of thing conservatives need to wise up i
can't believe
we've allowed ourselves to be duped i
can't believe those
extraordinarily naive or s or cynical
republicans who voted for impeachment
would allow themselves to be duped like
this i can't believe a member of the
republican leadership
would either fall for something like
that or ally herself with something like
that
really really pathetic really concerning
stuff
you know aoc was talking about allegedly
aggrieved minorities
and uh the left is always talking about
allegedly grieved minorities when they
can't find an agreement minority they'll
just invent one
well we did get some good news recently
for
an actually aggrieved minority you know
there's a
a real problem in this country uh where
whereby people will
abort babies on the basis of what they
consider to be
defects this is specifically true of
babies with down syndrome and it's
disgusting
but it happens all over the all over the
place you will
you'll go in i mean when you're about to
have a baby you go into the doctor to
say okay we're gonna do a screening you
know
and uh you know then we're gonna we're
gonna figure out if you know if they
have down syndrome or something like
that
then we can discuss our options
what options what do you mean options oh
the option is do you have the baby or do
you kill the baby do you kill the baby
because you don't think he's perfect
because he's got down syndrome or he's
got some other condition
that's the real thinking that goes on
and it's led to extraordinarily high
rates
of abortion of killing down syndrome
babies
and some countries boast about it you
know in iceland a few years ago
there was a big press release they said
iceland
has eradicated down syndrome
as if they cured a disease but there's
no cure for down syndrome it's not like
they
figured out some kind of gene therapy
that would fix
down syndrome they just kill them all
how ghastly is that and the left
cheering this on
yes we kill babies because they have
intellectual deficiencies
aren't we wonderful well uh governor
christie gnome in south dakota has just
just come out against this process she
says children with down syndrome are a
gift to us all
i'm asking the south dakota legislature
to pass a law that bans the abortion of
a pre-born child
just because that child is diagnosed
with down syndrome we must stand for the
right to life of every preborn child
absolutely right stuff and a good way by
the way
to to go after this issue you know there
what conservatives really want to do is
get rid of legal abortion
and some sometimes conservatives are
honest about that
i try to be honest about that uh
sometimes conservatives make these
really frivolous arguments where they
say you know abortion
we want to get rid of abortion because
it's bad for the mother
or it's it's harmful we want to protect
mothers and you know
i mean psychologically spiritually i
guess that's true but no you want to
protect the baby that's being killed
they'll say we you know we want to po we
want to
only have safe abortions and that's why
we're going to shut down the abortion
clinics because they're not
safe well no it's no abortion is safe it
kills a baby obviously that's not
you know they're all kind of somewhat
disingenuous arguments but they're
tactical and they think it's going to
chip away at the edges here and they
were fine by me this is a good way to do
it
this is actually a good way to do it
because you are appealing
to the moral standard that the left at
least pretends to have namely
that they oppose racism or sexism or
ableism ableism being
discrimination and bigotry against
people with handicaps
what if what if we passed a law and said
you can't
abort a baby just because he's black do
you think the left would object to that
i'm sure they'd find some way to object
to that but it'd be very difficult for
them to
what if we had a lot said you can't you
can't abort a baby just because she's a
girl
and that sort of thing does happen not
maybe not so much in the united states
yet but certainly around the world i
mean we saw that happen in china which
is why there's a lopsided population now
people were choosing boys and then
aborting the girls
what if we passed a law like christinom
says to
ban abortions of babies just because
they have intellectual deficiencies
i'm sure the left would find a way to
argue against it but it would be very
difficult argument it would make them
look very very ugly i think it would
move the needle and as as christy gnome
has this kind of
solid spine and i think real evidence of
political acumen
she is positioning herself very well for
2024 which a lot of people have been
talking about
you know i'm i'm noticing uh there have
been
some people coming out there was
actually a very prominent professor who
came out against christina
who said christinom your your state has
one of the highest
levels of kovid and kovid death and
covet hospitalization
in the country that's true it's up in
like the top five or top ten or
something
it's way below new york though and you
know you know andy cuomo
is being hailed by all of the left
christina put herself in a very very
good position and seems to have
a lot of moral clarity we don't get a
lot of wins these days on the right
however we did just get a win at the
supreme court
and this actually ties into everything
we were talking about about democracy
and the legitimacy of elections
and and how republicans are going to be
able to win moving forward
right now in texas there's a law that
says that you can't have universal
widespread mail-in ballots that you got
to request it and you've got to meet
certain criteria to get a mail-in ballot
democrats in texas challenged this law
they wanted to invent a constitutional
right
to universal mail-in ballots which is
ironic because as we have noted many
times on this show
there are states where the constitution
explicitly forbids
widespread mail-in ballots but democrats
challenge it anyway
goes all the way up to the supreme court
the supreme court rejected that bid the
supreme court rejected a democratic bid
for universal vote by mail in texas
leaving intact a state law now if
democrats take texas they can just get
rid of the law and then they'll have
universal widespread mail-in ballots
this is going to be a very important
issue
i think if republicans do not fight this
thing the universal widespread mail-in
it's going to be virtually impossible
for us to win important elections in the
future
a big win at the court we got to follow
it up though with legislative
achievements
speaking of dubious legal doctrines like
the right to a universal widespread
mailing
mayor bill de bolshevik in new york de
blasio
comes out he is severing the city's ties
with the trump organization
obviously donald trump has had a
long-standing relationship with the city
of new york
now the radical mayor there is going to
get rid of that relationship
according to a doctrine of the law that
doesn't seem to hold up to me
the city of new york is severing all
contracts with
the trump organization our legal team
has done an assessment and the contracts
make very clear
if a company in the leadership of that
company is engaged in criminal
activity we have the right to sever the
contract
uh inciting an insurrection let's be
clear i'm going to say these words again
inciting an insurrection against the
united states government
clearly constitutes criminal activity so
the city of new york will no longer have
anything to do with the
trump organization they have profited
from these contracts they will profit no
longer
so here's bill de blasio's argument
the trump organization has a contract
has multiple contracts with the city of
new york
and there are rules around these
contracts you can't just pull out
willy-nilly but you can pull out
if someone is engaging in criminal
activity
and therefore trump's engaging in
criminal activity therefore we can sever
the contract
what's the criminal activity bill well
the criminal activity is inciting an
insurrection
okay when was trump convicted of
inciting an insurrection
uh well he well he was impeached wasn't
he yes he was impeached when was he
convicted
impeachment is just a vote by the house
that then
sets up a trial and then the senators at
that trial convict
or acquit donald trump was never
convicted of inciting an insurrection
donald trump was never convicted of
inciting an insurrection in part because
he never incited an insurrection he
behaved recklessly he behaved
irresponsibly he shouldn't have done
that okay fine
sure maybe whatever he
obviously did not incite the
insurrection he said explicitly
be peaceful he said it before they went
to the capitol
he said be peaceful then he said it
while they were at the capitol
then he said it after they were at the
capitol
be peaceful same can't be said of maxine
waters who said get up in republicans
faces go to their homes where their
children sleep get up
get up on them this is the city of new
york in a severe ties with the waters
organization i guess there isn't one
is it enough now to just accuse somebody
of a crime
and and that has the full force of law
well apparently it is
right if i go out there and i say bill
de blasio is a communist
this guy is a red he is a pinko
he's a subversive he's seditious
uh does that now have the weight of law
have i convicted him of that crime
no i obviously can't do that one because
it would violate the law but two because
i'm a conservative but the left
can do that and that is what they're
doing and that's what they're about to
do
they're going to say you can't
do business you can't bank you can't
have your contracts you can't
go to certain places they're going to
try to continue this impeachment after
trump's
out of office it's not possible so i
suspect it'll fizzle pretty quickly but
there will be a movement at least among
democrats to do that
then i strongly suspect there are going
to be all sorts of investigations into
trump's personal life you can indict a
ham sandwich so they'll try to find
something
then i strongly suspect
there there's going to be a movement
among legislators to try to pass a law
saying trump can never run for office
again because they're so afraid of him
now that would violate the 14th
amendment so i don't think it would work
but who knows we're in a lawless era
we're in a lawless era now where a baker
can be sent out of business for not
engaging in a gay wedding that violates
his religious beliefs
but social media companies web companies
can censor outright based on any reason
they want
can refuse to engage in business with
anybody because
a mere accusation carries effectively
the force of law
someone goes out there and says 75
million americans are nazis that would
seem to be sufficient
to begin to silence them to begin to
ostracize them
to begin to exile them we're in the
beginning stages of that trump is still
the president
imagine how ramped up that is going to
get what a corrupt ruling elite
would do that sort of a thing and to
incur their ire
seems to me a badge of honor i'm michael
knowles this the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there